salut aujourd'hui c'est bientôt la fin
oui c'est bientôt la fin du jeu des
énigmes avec une énigme par jour pendant
les trente deux jours j'espère que vous
avez qui fait ce jeu cet été moi j'ai
vraiment tripé à mettre tout ça en place
et comme ces vidéos ont été faites en
avance ça veut dire que là en ce moment
je suis en train de carburait à mort
vous préparer les nouvelles vidéos qui
vont reprendre
bref avant de vous donner l'énigme
d'aujourd'hui la réponse de l'énigme
d'hier
si vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme dire
regardez la vidéo d'hier pour comprendre
l'énigme avant de connaître la réponse
donc la réponse est que mantes est un
mental et team et à l'eau font partie de
la tribu vlog ce que diallo ne peut pas
être vrai parce que s'il faisait tous
les trois parties la tribu vlog alors
aucun d'entre eux n'aurait pu le
l'avouer puisque vlog ment toujours
donc déjà on sait que halo et vlog de
fête et menthe ne peut pas faire partie
de la tribu vlog par contre parce que
s'il était ça voudrait dire que tim
serait le seul de la tribu mental et
dans ce cas-là l'affirmation demande
serait vrai ce qui pourrait pas être le
cas s'il faisait partie d'attributs vlog
puisque chez les blogs on ment tout le
temps voilà ça fait des petits nos
cerveaux mais c'est une je trouve une
énigme rigolote mais peut-être pas
autant que l'énigme du jour
énigme 31 l'avant dernière énigme alors
je vous écris une énigme de logique je
vais prendre un nom au hasard
sachez que ce nom ne reflète pas la
vérité évidemment le évidemment est un
indice sur le nom que j'ai pris trois
personnes parlent d'un youtuber le
premier dit pierrette un youtube heures
très très riche
il possède plus de dix voitures c'est
complètement faux répond le deuxième je
suis certain qu'il a moins de dix
voitures
le troisième dit écoutez on va se
détendre m disons qu'il a au moins une
voiture
donc sachant qu'il y a qu un seul des
trois immenses et qui est vrai combien
pierrade voiture comme d'habitude n'y a
pas d'embrouillé à une vraie réponse qui
vient d'une vraie logique qui nous
permet d'avoir la vraie réponse sûr et
certain à 100% et de pouvoir expliquer
pourquoi c'est la vraie réponse quand
vous avez trouvé la réponse mais t'es
juste j'ai trouvé dans les commentaires
et un pouce en l'air pour qu'on puisse
savoir le nombre de personnes qui aient
trouvé la bonne réponse mais n'écrivez
pas la réponse en est de même pour que
les autres puissent continuer à chercher
on le sait maintenant tout ça c'est
lundi donc bon courage pour cette
semaine pour ceux qui ont repris le
travail ou qui travaillent tout
simplement les autres profiter de la fin
des vacances profitez la fin de l'été
profitez-en aussi pour vous abonner
chen c'est important puisque le mental
blog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un
an donc rendez vous demain pour la
dernière énigme de cette série ciao